I like to keep my backpack up high in
front of me because I could rest my neck
on it today we're gonna do something
interesting we're gonna do something a
little bit outside of my box we're gonna
get a little high brown we're gonna get
pinky up fancy we're going to the
[ __ ] bro museum us to here our ghetto
is [ __ ] and we don't know [ __ ] about art
but here's the thing I'm open to new
experiences I'm open to learn now for me
all I know is half the time I look at
contemporary art I think that is a piece
of [ __ ] but I'm pretty sure there's
going to be a lot of amazing pieces in
there that's just gonna blow me the [ __ ]
away and there are gonna be a few pieces
in there that's gonna make me want to
burn that [ __ ] down
so we're gonna go inside see what's up
see what's poppin see what's good there
you go give them a little dance please
do it it's [ __ ] weird they should do
a screening test for ghetto people
because me and Ellen I don't think we
really know anything about art and
here's the thing if I don't know about
something I can't pretend like I do it's
not a part of me I'm a very honest human
being first of all I had no idea that
museum was called broad its felt broad
and that's what it is but everybody's
attacking me they're like oh actually
you uncultured brute it's actually
burrowed well [ __ ] you so you're telling
me right now that this is worth a
significant amount of money
this thing where they took a piece of
paper they cut it out and then they
painted in between the lines and this is
worth my [ __ ] I could do this [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] kidding me right now dog run
we're gonna do a Korean version it's
called bond money the other rich people
just sit around like you know what dog
run my dog runs million dollars [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
I have a stain on one of my boxers that
looks like Australia millions of dollars
would you like to buy it yup there's a
lot of hype about the bro museum and I
don't know what to expect but I prefer
it that way so I don't come in with any
negative notions so I could judge the
art in a very negative manner I want to
be like water my friend you put water
into the puppy becomes the cop Bruce Lee
this is Andy Warhol's thing of Marilyn
Monroe also known as the most famous
hooker of all time if you asked me what
was my favorite thing that I observed in
the museum was the hipsters observing
art asking their friends to take a
picture of them observing art because
you want to look like a cultured [ __ ] so
in LA we have something called crazy
[ __ ] bloggers where they do artistic
shots I've been looking at [ __ ] even
though they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're looking at watch
[ __ ] amazing do that for me - I'm
absurd the blogger's observing their
[ __ ] amazing perception I swear I saw
this like under a bridge in LA this
looks like something on Skid Row I saw
this at Toys R Us yesterday or you can
enjoy the rest looking for small
children you know what we should do I'm
gonna get a thumbtack and I'm gonna put
this on the wall and then just put up
like a bunch of words next to it and
watch a blogger go up to and be like
this if those squares and those dots on
the walls is any indication of what I'm
going to expect out of this museum just
shoot me now and I know what you're
thinking Oh David you don't understand
art yes I do I do understand that piece
you're supposed to say that hey why does
it have to be the centerpiece that's the
art why can't it be the actual space
around it [ __ ] you I call this emoji
eyebrows do you understand anything that
you're looking at in here big that's
what I saw before you [ __ ] killing me
right now Joey knows this shit's work
her child has something like that it's
called a sippy cup and I saw somebody
over they will take your picture they're
like this is amazing although you will
go [ __ ] yourself anyway
I'm putting paint on my ass tomorrow and
I'm sitting on a canvas and I'm selling
that [ __ ] it's called [ __ ] you in the
ass that's what huh four million dollars
thank you I thought I was crazy good you
guys are the only normal people here now
I'm not saying I'm over here and talking
[ __ ] about every single art piece at the
pro because that would be completely
wrong there was a lot of things that I
enjoyed from there but personally I like
historical pieces because you get to see
progression and art and kind of a lot of
where these influences stem from so when
you walk into this place it's just a
little overwhelming for me because I see
a lot of art that I want to burn too
yes their skills involved with this I
thought that was a little chip photo and
it's not even if it were the photo
that's a pretty [ __ ] amazing photo are
you telling me right now that this is in
the [ __ ] brownie Museum I can [ __ ]
do this
and you know people say oh if you could
do that why don't you I did I was three
years old they threw it away I got a F
are you [ __ ] kidding me I did that
all the time as a teenager and I got in
trouble for it none of my charcoal dicks
were displayed as artwork
none of it would had any kind of
monetary value and you're telling me
right now there's a whole bunch of
people standing in front of that [ __ ]
right now saying oh I could see the
influent
it's a charcoal [ __ ] dick as a
disclaimer ghetto people you know what
I'm talking about right like this
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
I drew this [ __ ] on my desk in high
school and I got suspended and somebody
is making money off of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
all my teachers who told me to stop
doing that [ __ ] I feel a bit rich don't
even get me started with that
kindergarten desktop scribble Scrabble C
+ 6 - [ __ ] thing that was worth a
gajillion dollars and I need somebody
out there to explain to me why that is
amazing heart not that [ __ ] that you
read on the placard but really convinced
me you piece of [ __ ] if you put this in
the house of any Korean parent they
would be so mad at you so you spend
three million a dollar on this a piece
of a [ __ ]
that is a from your younger brother who
the idiot once again I'm gonna just say
this not everything there is garbage and
remember art is very subjective so I
have my personal opinions about a lot of
things that I saw but there are a lot of
great political and social artwork that
was there and there were a great amount
of things that actually did blow my mind
but of course if you don't like art and
you just have no interest in it will
just come anyways try to open your mind
a little bit just like I did or if
that's not the case you just walk
through and just talk [ __ ] about
everything this is a photo of Israel
Israeli soldiers searching Palestinian
men which is a very deep deep and very
hard photo to look
and then we just had a nice picture of a
budget Asian tourists raising up their
hands imitating it because II think it's
fun no that's so [ __ ] funny and not
the that what's going on is just that
they're completely oblivious they don't
know it happens a lot just because you
know you don't read the language and is
easily understandable is just hilarious
I'm not gonna say I'm a big fan of
Takashi Murakami I actually don't know a
lot of his artwork but what I do know
him from is that he actually did the
cover art for one of Kanye West's albums
so I personally love this stuff it's
very vibrant it's very colorful
some people might say that my art
purposes are very shallow it's very in
now you're not really looking too deep
well once again and I've said this
before [ __ ] you all right I like what I
like and I love Takashi Murakami stuff
sir
if I ever meet you in person can you
please turn me into a piece of art naked
we're out here with a jackhammer and
goddamn that's [ __ ] loud that's art
haha yeah but uh you know I know that I
was clouded a lot on a lot of the art
pieces in there that's just because I
don't understand and you know sometimes
too I feel like when I look at art
people tell me that I have to feel a
certain way about it no I don't I could
think that it's garbage you would say
that I have a very shallow way of
thinking however if you go to the
downstairs area there was a few pieces
that for example you saw something that
you really like yes I liked one that
talked about feminism and that was
really cool because once you when you
look at it and it's interesting and once
you know you get you dive into the
history of it
it's really cool
you learn something from it and you're
actually touched somehow you know like I
felt I was really touched as a woman you
know when you describe you dance but you
know social like political peace and
those kind of things I get it cuz even
when you look at the pastry life oh I
wonder what this is about you know some
of the other ones though like the
scribbles travel painting and you're
telling me that's worth millions and I
have a daughter that does that already
at home every single day and you're
telling me that what she does is not
worth million that's false that good
people and how we interpret hard and
that's what you're thinking right but
that's dumb too because I'm pretty sure
if you went up to this piece and it was
in my house and not in this museum you'd
be like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
why would you put that [ __ ] up there it
is unless how I kind of generally view
the art to look at in see both does it
make me feel a certain way and if it
doesn't that is what it is I'm in terms
of my opinion you I'm saying
but live out loud live out loud feet
come here come to the broad Museum of a
man who has a billion dollars he's so
rich all he doesn't collect art oh I
wish I was he